go ahead and get started welcome
everyone to the usual Thursday the mice
informatics research conference and we
have this week as we have many weeks
throughout the year a student
presentation we're going to hear from
Jeffrey hunter as he does his master's
thesis proposal defense which means that
he's going to present his proposed
master's thesis work to us and we will
give him comments and feedback and then
when the general audience has done the
his committee will sort of stay a little
afterwards and further work out the
details with him and then once he's
approved on that process as many of you
know we'll be able to go on and do his
master's thesis so the title of his talk
is expression variations associated
associated with influenza infection
severity and humans and mice as a human
who's just getting over something that
was probably influenza I'll be
interested to hear although I don't
think my genome has been sequenced yet
maybe there we go yes thank you so he
said my name is Jeffrey hunter and I'm
talking about my proposal for my thesis
which is looking at the expression
variation associated with influenza
infection so to start with the World
Health Organization estimates that five
to ten percent of adults and twenty
thirty percent of children are infected
with influenza annually of these there
are an estimated three to five million
severe cases which can results in
between 250 to 500 thousand deaths each
year these infections are of course
caused by the influenza virus of which
there are three types a B and C the B&C
viruses only affect humans while VA
viruses are able to infect a wide range
of hosts additionally there are several
subtypes of da viruses which are
categorized by two viral proteins
hemagglutinin and neuraminidase
currently of various subtypes h1n1 and
h3n2 are the most common in humans for a
general uncomplicated influenza
infection symptoms generally include
fever cough sore throat muscle pain
nasal congestion things like that in
order to be classified as a severe
infection hover there's four criteria
that the World Health Organization
defines the first is if a patient
presents with any specific complications
these can include lower respiratory
tract disease such as shortness of
breath or pneumonia central nervous
system involvement edges encephalopathy
or encephalitis secondary complications
including respiratory failure septic
shock or multiple organ failure and
other complications such as dehydration
or myocarditis additionally if the
patient has any sort of chronic
condition that's exacerbated by an
influenza infection their infection
would also be classified as severe
likewise if
patient has any other condition either
caused by or in addition to an influenza
infection that requires hospitalization
that infection is also severe and lastly
if a patient presents with what is
initially an uncomplicated infection and
then progresses into something more
severe through one of the other
categories it's considered that their
entire svet infection was severe so from
these it's pretty clear that there's
significant variation in the symptoms
observed and unsurprisingly there's also
a large number of factors that can
contribute to the range of symptoms and
severity is experienced as one might
imagine both this strain quantity of
virus one is exposed to certain plays a
role as do plenty of environmental
factors around patients additionally
there are quite a few differences
between patients that lead to these age
is definitely strongly correlated with
the very young and the very old being
much more likely to have severe
infections chronic conditions obviously
play a role in the rate of severe
infections as well and there also does
seem to be quite a significant genetic
component as well so this complexity
underlying and influenza infection has
made it rather difficult to tease apart
the contributions of the individual
components that are basically going into
this infection severity so what we'd
like is the use of a more controllable
model that can potentially shed light on
each of the components a bit more
readily one of these that's been
commonly used in biology and influenza
specifically has been inbred mouse lines
they've allowed for identification of
several genetic factors so far but
unfortunately don't accurately represent
the genetic diversity found in an out
bread human population in order to
combat this the recently developed
collaborative cross makes use of eight
parental strains that are out bread in a
controlled manner in order to more
accurately represent human genetic
diversity while still maintaining quite
a bit of the reproducibility that was
the hallmark of the inbred lines
in order to make use of the data from
the collaborative cross then it's very
important for us to have computational
tools that allow us to access and
understand the data that we've collected
much of this is done the framework of
ontologies which are structured and
controlled vocabularies that basically
describe and annotate a body of
knowledge they work by defining the
vocabulary the structure of the ontology
and then defining the relationship
between each of those objects for many
of the anthologies out there they're
divided definitely by species and often
by information as well so for instance
the human phenotype ontology and the
mouse phenotype ontology are very
separate and different entities while
the terms and relationships within each
ontology are fairly consistent there are
much greater differences between
different ontologies this has
unfortunately limited the ability to
integrate data across species and has
only compounded difficulties caused by
different conceptualizations of
phenotypes and species-specific
anatomy's there has however been some
progress in the last few years in being
able to map related terms in different
ontologies the monarch initiative for
instance has established tools that
allow for some computational comparison
between species and involved mapping
related terms and different ontologies
and making use of overarching super
classes to basically bridge the
connection between them such mappings
will be essential for my project here in
order to integrate both human and mouse
influenza infection data on the human
side of things then I planning on
looking at expression data taken from
the gene expression omnibus the
expression data sets have been looked at
and selected the ones that I'm wanting
to use so far have to include influenza
severity annotation with severity
definitions equivalent to the World
Health Organization guidelines I
them to have the raw microarray data
available and lastly to have virus data
rather than or potentially in addition
to vaccine data from there I needed to
decide whether I was wanting to look at
the important genes or try and go more
broadly and look at pathways initially
in this project I was rather excited to
try and find some sort of causal
difference for influenza severity but
from looking at basically the data in
the arrays it quickly became apparent
that it's probably not the most
practical the micro arrays for the human
data sets just can't capture all of the
expression variation and there are quite
a number of different arrays that have
been used in the data sets as well which
is limited to direct comparisons that I
can make on the gene level additionally
as one of the main outcomes for my
project just going to be basically
establishing a framework for
prioritizing further QTL studies and
ongoing projects it seemed the more
generalizable application would be to
branch out to pathways as well to that
end then I'm proposing the following
specific aims from I t's excusing the
first is to identify public human data
sets with influenza infection severity
annotation to rate analyze and integrate
these data in order to identify key
pathways genes and regions implicated in
influenza severity and response to
infection the second is to establish a
mapping of human influenza infection
severity phenotypes and genes in the
mouse model in this case the
collaborative cross and ensure that
these mappings can be extended to other
mouse models lastly I plan to use the
established collaborative excusing use
the established across species phenotype
and candidate gene mappings in order to
provide a computational framework to
guide prioritization in collaborative
cross studies for identification of
genetic and gene pathway associations
related to influenza infection severity
my proposed research then is focused on
mining human phenotype and expression
studies and ultimately will provide
guidance and a computational framework
for identifying candidate genes in
collaborative cross mapping studies
currently I've created an initial set of
human data sets from GL and having done
so I now also have an analytical
pipeline established so that if I come
across more in the course of this
project I should be able to quickly add
them to the existing data sets go into a
little more detail on what I've been
doing well this one is a sort of a
general flow of the project basically
I'm looking at it sort of as two parts
the first is working with the ohsu
Oncology Group to establish more
deontology mappings and extend the
monarch initiative in order to relate
the data between the human and mouse
data and the second for the statistical
analysis i'll be using our and several
packages from bioconductor in order to
identify differential expression and
over-represented pathways for the
ontology mapping part I will need a few
pieces of information the first
obviously would be the names of ontology
terms that are related but don't yet
have clean mapping and in order to help
make sure we identify the right ones and
map properly i'll also need to grab the
parent terms reach from there i'll also
need a textual definition to extend the
annotations and a reference that I can
cite between the terms while it is
possible for me to attain and extend a
local copy of the cross pc mappings this
presents two problems the first is that
it wouldn't particularly assist anyone
else in future research along these
lines and the second is I'm quite liable
to deviate from the controlled terms in
those ontology having spoken with couple
members of the ontology group sounds
like they should be able to quickly add
any mappings and help me extend the live
copies pretty quickly
so if at all possible my plan is to
follow the best practices here and work
with them to extend the live mappings
for the statistical side of things I
it's again breaking broken down into two
parts the first for the human data sets
I've taken all of the published results
from the data sets and recorded the
significantly differentially expressed
genes then pulling in the annotations
from the microarray platforms used I've
constructed a consistent table with gene
name directionality of the expression as
well as gene button excuse me Jen bank
and NCBI ideas that tables then gotten
past to our and pulling in the ghost
stats package I've been able to identify
significantly over-represented pathways
as well as the genes that were
responsible for identifying those
pathways on the mouse side of things the
first step is going to be taking the
more quantitative phenotype measurements
that we have and establishing a concrete
severity using severe infection
definition in order to stratify the
uncomplicated versus severe infections
once I have that established I'll then
pass the microwave data into our and
making use probably the packages lima
and a fee I'll identify the
differentially expressed genes as well
as getting the ids that i need for each
and then similar to the human side of
things olin go stats in order to
identify the represented pathways and
genes from the match datasets
with this project the main limitation
that I touched on a little bit
definitely seems to be the micro reigns
as I said they're unable to fully
capture all of the expression data and
especially on the human data sets each
one I've looked at so far makes use of
either a different version or a
different platform in each study which
definitely limits the direct gene level
comparisons I can make to further
complicate just the human data sets the
samples have unfortunately all been
taken from different time points in each
study one of them was from a single time
point one of them has to one of them was
over the course of four to five days so
trying to get all of that line up nicely
may be a bit tricky as well the other
issue between the human and the mouse
data sets is that the human studies have
all made use of blood samples while the
mouse data has been collected with lung
samples there's unfortunately not much
way to go back and either get lung
samples from the humans or blood samples
from the mice at this point which is
unfortunate but hopefully we'll be able
to make that comp was still useful and
informative information the other main
limitation that I may run into would be
issues with the ontology mappings being
somewhat limited since extending the
ontology xand the mappings may require
some development with the group's
maintaining the anthologies it's
possible it may take a bit more time
than I have given the short timeline of
this thesis but I'm hopeful I can get at
least most of it lined up so at the
completion of this project it's my
expectation that I'll have identified
genetic and expression variation that's
correlated excuse me it's correlated
with differences and observed symptoms
in mice and humans and that I'll have
utilize these to establish a framework
for prioritizing findings of genetic and
gene pathway studies related to
influenza infection severity
in order to do so I've had the following
timeline outlined the first part has
been to look at the human data sets and
that pretty much running out of time I
was allocating until the end of January
to finish adding data sets to that I'm
currently working with the ontology
group in order to extend the mappings
and after which I'll obtain the mouse
data and begin to analyze those at the
same time I've been performing
literature review will be working on the
actual thesis document itself and
finally the defense of the thesis I
fully understand that they're quite
possibly going to be some delays in here
so I have also allocated a month between
my intended conclusion of the project
and the final deadline and with that I'd
like to thank my committee members for
their ongoing health and thank you guys
for your attention personal Jeffrey
thank you so i can really interesting
topic he spoke very clear that was great
hey um I don't understand one thing
though when you're looking at your human
subjects genomic data what are the
inclusion criteria for the study and how
are you going to avoid just getting
indicators for severe chronic disease
rather what makes it differentially
susceptible to flu I'm okay so you get
severe influenza is of course much more
likely in somebody a COPD or heart
failure or liver disease or something
like that for which there is a large set
of genomic markers and we're working on
already how are you going to
differentiate the things that make you
more likely for severe influenza beyond
that are you just going to come up with
the markers for these diseases
as of yet I'm not entirely short part of
it has to do with the actual people who
were taken most of the subjects for the
human datasets have basically they're
selected based more on respiratory
issues rather than other complications
like that which should help somewhat
with end so focusing more on like the
respiratory failure part of severe
infections rather than exacerbation of
existing chronic condition beyond that
it's a bit hard to say and definitely
something I should look into thank you
right
yeah that's one that at this point I
haven't douve too much into the actual
like process that I'm going to be using
for it so I at this point don't have
like this uh these are the steps that
I'm going to be doing in order to create
that so the ontology mapping part is
basically to relate that this phenotype
these jeans etc founded mice can be
mapped to these similar things in humans
but in terms of creating the purchasing
prioritization framework itself that's
one that I'm still working on
development
ideally both
and that is definitely what I'm more
focusing on but it would be nice to be
able to have that for the genes as well
so you know I think the idea is that you
can have classify your candidate genes
based on the phenotypes of one species
and then use the mappings it implicit in
the ontology to help prioritize the
candidates based on both phenotypic
similarity and morphology and then you
could extend that to other pathway
members depending on what kinds of
relationships you might want to utilize
for that prioritization so that you
start out with you know 300 candidates
that might be particularly relevant in
human that you could then using the
phenotypic similarity to the mouse
potentially reduce that number of genes
of interest based on a variety of
factors including pathway membership or
phenotypic similarity so there's always
a danger in a bioinformatics student
undertaking a study as clinical types
can actually understand and so my my no
it's very interesting and I totally
understand what you want to do and and
deon actually asked the question that I
was also going to ask and Shannon
emphasizes its importance but another
aspect of this and I don't know how
familiar you are with kind of the sort
of biology around influenza but what
kinds of lessons would a sort of
biological researcher who understands
influenza and the genetics behind it and
so forth be able to kind of take away
from your study to pursue new avenues of
research the
that would ultimately result in clinical
observations well the main goal for it
would be not so much to say that this is
what's causing it or I think what's
causing it it would I mean it would be
nice if I could come up with that but I
more expect to have something that
basically allows you to say you've done
this study come up with this list of
possible genes that you think are
interested i have found from this data
mining that this set of genes looks to
be implicated the ones that overlap are
possibly more likely to be useful
possibly consider focusing your research
in that area yeah can I try and respond
to dr. hersh's question one thing
they're looking at doing is using the
result of this type of study to identify
what needs to go in the influenza
vaccines so we take and we identify what
the genetic variants are for the people
who are like they have severe illnesses
and make sure we package the vaccine so
it's going to help those people to be
more resistant to flu
wow we collecting dust
coming